(applause)
- Oh my gosh.
- Oh my goodness.
- You look very dapper.
- You're very sweet,
you look very beautiful.
- Oh, thank you
It's a team of people.
- Same here.
I love that you have a
Botox station in the back.
(hysterical laughter)
I feel so good.
- Then I haven't used it.
- And your audience is so beautiful.
- They're here without masks.
I love that you've noticed that,
it has taken a minute to
get here, Michael, so yeah.
- I noticed the second I
was watching on the Mo...,
I saw a guy out there.
I don't know where he is now but,
he was so..
had a blue shirt and suspenders.
And I thought, look at how,
- You can see his smile.
- There he is, Look at you go.
- You look so lovely.
- You look so cool.
Wait, the last time we saw each other,
I know we've run into each
other several times but,
the last time, was it at the voice?
I don't remember.
- I think so, and then the time before,
I think we had dinner with Blake.
- Yeah, with Blake, at Cory?
- At Cory or somewhere?
- Yeah, that was fun.
We all drank.
- I think my sisters came and everything
- Yeah, It was good.
- Yeah.
- I love their food.
Well, congrats though,
you have a new baby now.
(applause) Is it four?
Is it four?
I'm like y'all make some babies.
- Thank you,
Well, you too, you make beautiful babies.
- Yes, but two.
- Yeah, That's true.
I think once you hit
two, three, it's always-
- They start playing with each other,
and so yeah, that's-
- So yeah, my wife, were really
excited to be expecting and,
I'm really lucky that she loves me and
- Did you want a fourth or was it like a,
whoopsy,
like, was it like (all laughing)
- It was, you know what,
I wanted the fourth, but it was,
it definitely was, a Whoopsy.
- Yeah.
- I'm just saying most,
I feel like most,
sometimes third or fourths are.
- No, we wanted it.
I think I just was more excited,
and I think, I wanted to...
I'm digging myself into a Deep hole.
I wanted, you know-
- So she was more excited.
- She, well, I liked the part
about making it, so much.
(all laughing)
I think that's the part
that I was really into that.
- touché.
- And then what's really funny is,
so on Christmas Eve,
we told the kids.
And we were like,
there's a baby coming.
- Yeah.
And my little boy Eli, who's five.
I think, yours are seven and,
- Five and seven
- Five and seven, so the five year old,
he was devastated.
And we were like,
what? you don't want a?
And he said, "No."
He said,
"Why didn't you invite
me when you fell in love
and made the baby?"
- Oh my gosh.
- Yeah. And I I still don't
know how to answer that.
- Cause you don't live in the mountains
and some things you don't share.
- You just don't.
We're not that kind of family.
Like it's, yeah.
My kids are,
they want me to have one.
They constantly come
home and they're like,
"Is there a baby in there?"
And I'm like, I know it
might appear so but no.
I was like, no baby.
They're dying for me to have a baby,
'cause their older sister had a baby.
And so now they just
want a baby in the house.
So I'm like, "If I had a
baby, you would be so jealous,
you would not want me to have one."
- Yeah, no, no, no, yeah,
- But it is true that once you have
like a certain amount kids,
they do start playing with each other.
It's kind of cool.
- You know what,
it's the greatest thing
that ever happened to me
and I don't wanna,
be all gooey about it but,
- It's true.
- It goes so fast, and,
- (whispering) It does.
I mean my little,
my eight year old is,
he's growing into a little dude,
and so I need,
I just need more.
I need more.
And this is it.
I think my wife is, that's it, so,
- My little girl is literally
almost as tall as me
and she's almost eight
and I'm just short.
But she's like almost as tall as me.
And I'm like, wait, what happened?
I was like, where did it go?
I don't know where it went.
It does fly.
It's such a cliche, but
I'm so happy for y'all.
- Thank you so much.
You're such a beautiful family.
So you announced the pregnancy,
was it in a music Video?
- Yeah. You know,
I had that music video
"Haven't Met You Yet."
Which was 14 years ago.
And when I started
conceptualizing my girlfriend,
Amy Foster came up with this
idea of going through cinema,
and I was like, you know what,
why can't this be in the
Bubble cinematic universe,
the Lo Pilato,
where we go from,
"Haven't Met You Yet."
And we turned the next video for,
"I'll never not love you." into a sequel.
And so we go through
all my favorite movies,
and at the end we figure
out that I'm an idiot.
And I was daydreaming again,
just like I was in the
first video, and so,
I love that M Night Shyamalan
sort of twist at the end.
And then I thought,
how cool to show the world,
we're pregnant again.
- And how special,
your baby, later on will be like,
"That was me."
- That was me, exactly.
- That's so cool.
I love that. I love that.
So where are you living these days?
You still in Canada?
- Yeah, I live in Vancouver.
I mean, I work everywhere, but yeah.
The home is in Vancouver and then,
Argentina back and forth.
- It's so,
okay, so I got a ranch in Montana because
it's the closest thing I feel like,
just geographically speaking
like how beautiful it is.
It's the closest thing I
can get to British Columbia.
- Really?
Yeah, 'Cause in the United States,
it's just like so beautiful,
but I love it where you are
- Yeah, they're my people.
Like I I'll never go and
I don't know why anybody...
if you're born and raised there,
I don't know why you go.
- It's so beautiful.
- Yeah.
- But you seem very into
TikTok, I love this.
You like TikTok a lot?
- I do. You know what, I love,
I'm a creative person and you're a crea...
You get it, I love making fun of myself.
- Oh I love self deprication.
- I have so much fun.
I mean, when I make them,
I seriously laugh my ass off,
before they're ever out.
I realize how stupid they are.
And I'm like, I lo...
Like, who cares what anyone thinks?
- But it's so funny, that juxtaposition of
how classy you are on tour,
'cause I've seen you
on tour and you're like
straight up just the classiest guy ever,
and very funny.
- Thank you.
You know what's funny, the music itself,
yeah obviously it's
very romantic and sexy.
But, my favorite parts of the show
are in between when,
I get to con...
like you,
I feel like I'm very similar to you
- You like connecting.
- I love connecting to people.
I love what you're doing right now,
to be able to
connect to beautiful souls
like this and to be real,
- It's such, yeah.
(applause)
So I have to ask about this
specific TikTok though.
What going on here?
is my question.
Are you being attacked,
by a gorilla?
- What were you on?
(Michael groaning)
Was your alcohol involved?
- There were no alcohol.
I don't know.
- Did you just see it and you were like-
- I saw one,
- Give me bananas.
I saw one on TikTok.
I was like I get it.
It's like crack, it really is.
You can't...
I go to bed at night and I'm like,
"I'll just look at like
10 I'll look at 10."
And I find myself at two
in the morning going,
"I can't stop."
- Oh my gosh.
And so I saw one where this
little dude did this thing
and it says, "Oh my
God, it's Jason Bourne.
And I was like,
- I thought that you're Jason Bourne.
(all laughing)
- Yeah, And I was like,
how can I come off this,
and look as terrible as...
I was wearing like,
I think I was wearing
my wife's jogging pants and ugg boots,
and like, anyway, it's-
- I would love to be able to fit
in your wife's jogging pants.
- I think it's hilarious.
I just thought it was
hilarious and there's-
- oh my God, I love it.
There's more idiocy coming.
- Okay. I'm into it.
It's entertaining.
So wait, you went to Argentina recently
where your wife's from.
- Yeah.
So do you love go going there?
Like what do y'all do there?
- Oh, I love arge...
Yeah, it's a great country.
Great, really great people.
Who just said Woohoo?
- See, there you go.
Shout out.
- You're from Argentina?
- Are you serious?
- Oh, Beautiful, (speaking
in foreign language)
- That's some crazy
happenstance, like what?
- It's a big country.
My wife will say,
"Argentina, We have the
best women, the best meat,
the best football. We have the pope."
- We have
- We have the pope.
So no, well when I go there,
it's usually 'cause my wife makes movies.
She's a big movie star.
- Oh yeah.
So I'm the set bitch.
I go,
(all laughing)
That's what I am.
- So I'm that guy.
- I'm that guy.
I show up,
I bring this stuff.
I get the trailer all ready.
Maybe a little massage,
and take care of the kids.
And you know,
set bitch, get me some water.
Set bitch, (speaking foreign language)
- Y'all need your own show.
Okay wait, let's talk
about your new music.
So wait, so the album is called "Higher".
So what's the vibe for this?
I love the cover, by the
way, it's be very mysterious.
Like are you coming from somewhere?
Are you going?
- thank you very much.
I don't know.
- "Higher"-
- It feels like Matthew
McConaughey is gonna ride up
in that commercial, you know,
- All right, all right, all right.
- Yeah, exactly.
It's a great cover.
- Yeah It's a pretty nice cover.
(Kelly laughing)
- So what's it like?,
I'll tell you what, it's, you're
I love that,
just so that you know,
you are one of my first
interviews for this record,
and I'm so grateful that
I get to talk to you,
a fellow recording artist,
because you'll understand when I say this
more than anyone ever will.
I've made the greatest
record of my life and,
- Oh really?
Yeah, and I've come out of it-
- I love that feeling.
(applause)
- Thanks.
And I came out of a,
I would say bit of a rough decade.
The family's been through a lot.
- Yeah.
And there were points where
I don't know how I survived,
and yet to come out and to have,
have had this come together.
I can't believe it's happening.
And I'm-
- So these songs are special, yeah.
- Dude, I need to be in the moment,
and appreciate every moment
of what's gonna happen,
because I really think
it's downhill from here.
I really do.
(Kelly laughing hysterically)
I think there's a bunch of Grammy's,
and a bunch of good things coming,
and all that love.
And it's probably just
gonna go (beep) after this.
(all laughing)
- No, it's not wait,
but this is amazing 'cause
you also worked with
Sir Paul McCartney on this
record, that's amazing.
- Yeah.
- Did he produce you?
- Is that what it-
He produced, yeah.
- What, it was that conversation like,
"Hi, sir."
- It was,
yeah, will you produce, will you come?
And there was a song that,
it was a great song that he wrote
and I asked him if he would produce.
And he said yes.
And I got very quiet on the phone.
And he thought he, he had lost me
and he said,
"Hello?"
this is really true too.
He said, "Hello, hello?
And I said "Hi."
And he said, "Oh, I thought I lost you."
And I said, "no."
I said, "I just pooped my pants."
- I'll be right back.
- Because I was like, what the,
this is happening.
And, this whole record was...
I mean, Willie Nelson.
I mean, he's my hero dude.
And get to sing crazy with Willie and,
get to write-
- What did the studio smell like?
(all laughing)
- I don't remember, I don't remember.
- What was one of your favorites though,
to do on the record?
- I think "Higher" was
easily, one of my...
This is weird, but my,
one of the title tracks, "Higher",
Was co-written by my eight year old.
- Oh
- Yeah, he came into,
I was giving the kids a shower
and doing the shampoo
and stuff and he said,
"Poppy, I wrote a song."
and I said, go for it.
And he said,
♪ When you go low ♪
♪ and I'd go high, ♪
♪ dun dun dun ♪
And I said like, this
is good. Like, really?
And then I thought, "Did
you hear that on YouTube?"
I freaked out
- Scouring.
I was like, "Where did
you hear that, honey?"
He said like, "No, no, I wrote it."
And I said, but really?
- Yeah, what show were you watching?
- And then I sat with
Ryan tater and Greg Wells
and we were,
on a writing session, yeah
And I said,
I panicked.
"Hey, can I sing this song
my eight year old...?"
And I sang it and they were
like, "This is really good."
And then we came up with this song,
and now it's happening.
And I did a,
my son is gonna be rich.
- How cool is that though?
That you did it,
that's so cool.
I love we're such a...
You do turn into like a mush
pot when you become a parent.
Cause you're like,
how can I involve my
children in my projects?
- I didn't mean to honestly
and even after that writing session
I came home and I kept
saying, are you sure?
'Cause, then I was really panicking
and he went to the piano,
and he said, "no, look."
And he went,(making piano sound)
- I love that.
- Yeah, it's amazing, yeah
- But it's so fun to see your kid, like,
'cause we love art
and it's like our therapy
and it's like our bloodline.
So like it's like in us.
- I always say this.
Like it is,
People often come to me,
I'm sure they do to you.
And they'll say like,
"Oh my son or my daughter,
they want to do this."
And I'll always say to them, listen,
they are so blessed.
The gift of the romance with music
is the greatest romance I'll ever.
No man, no woman will ever break their-
- The relationship that
won't let you down.
- You will always have that,
and it is the deepest, most purest level.
Like when I hear music,
it is like the voice of God speaking, so,
- Yeah.
I'm so happy for you for this record.
That's so cool.
- Thank you so much.
I know that feeling,
of like making something you're,
truly proud of every part of it.
- Obviously I'm proud of
my other records, but it's,
- Me too, but there are
ones that are special.
- It's been a while since
I've written songs like this
and gone like,
"Oh my God, I think
I'm gonna have a hits".
- I love that feeling.
- That's a weird feeling.
Yeah, yeah, And it feels good.
Yeah, especially when you step out of
being like a parent
and you're like, wait, this is what I do.
- Totally.
This is like, yeah.
You're like, I'm cool, wait.
So wait, you're performing a song today,
and it's called, "I'll
never not love you."
- "I'll Never not Love You."
What's that about, other
than never not loving them.
- I think it's about the greatest,
I think it's about the gift,
The greatest gift you
can ever give or receive.
And when my mom had us and we were little,
she used to tell us over and over again,
that unconditional love
was the greatest thing
you could ever give anybody.
And so I think that's
what the song is about.
I think it's about all
of us have been hurt.
All of us have been put in a
place where we're vulnerable
and we're scared to go through it again.
And this is me saying to that person,
listen, fall into me, trust me.
And,
it's not gonna happen again
- Fall Into me.
Okay sir.
That's a nice line.